[Musique]
les bandes noires ce mystère pourtant si
proche de nous
pourquoi sont-elles là
nouvelle telle du mal comment les
apprivoiser qui pourra bien mettez à
vous en parler
bonjour je suis art disque et vous
regardez la chaîne explique mans encore
parce que je suis un peu bête et j'ai
besoin qu'on m'explique deux fois les
choses et salut à tous les amis c'est
françois pour la chaîne explique moi
encore je suis ravi de vous retrouver
une nouvelle fois sur cette chaîne pour
parler de vidéo
d'ailleurs j'ai plein de choses à vous
dire à propos de la chaîne mais ça sera
à la fin de la vidéo donc rester bien
jusqu'au bout c'est super important
et aujourd'hui on va donc parler en
profondeur de ces fameuses bandes noires
qui donne cet effet cinéma on va
découper ça en trois parties la première
ça va être sur le pourquoi un d'où ça
sort parce que c'est toujours important
de savoir pourquoi les choses sont là
avant d'essayer de les faire
la deuxième ce sera justement sur
comment on s'y prend pour reproduire ces
bandes noires et enfin dans la troisième
partie on verra comment un peu de bide
mis un petit peu ces bandes noires pour
ajouter un petit plus être un peu plus
créatifs et sans plus attendre on va
commencer par la première partie sur la
partie théorique pourquoi les bandes
noires mais pour vous expliquer ça je
vais laisser la place à l'incontournable
que dis-je au prodigieux ar disque
aujourd'hui françois m'a demandé de vous
parler un petit peu des bandes noires au
cinéma et pourquoi il y en a parce que
de prime abord ça a l'air de servir à y
est il faut savoir que quand on parle de
bandes noires au cinéma on parle en fait
da spectre est chiant c'est à dire en
fait le format du fichier vidéo par
exemple le plus connu actuellement dans
notre monde moderne c'est le 16/9 c'est
un format qui est représenté avec deux
chiffres un pour la largeur 1 pour la
longueur comme par exemple bas 16 9ème
et c'est un chiffre qui a beaucoup
changé avec l'histoire faut savoir que
les premières télévisions notamment les
télévisions qui était en noir et blanc
et même après les premières et des
couleurs je crois était en 4/3 c'était
pas des rectangles comme on a maintenant
c'était plus des carrés et à l'époque
c'était simple tout est tourné dans ce
format les émissions télé était tourné
en format carré les films aussi bref les
parents de questions à se poser sauf
qu'ensuite il ya eu l'avènement du
cinéma à 35 mm à mes couilles et donc
est venu le problème qu'on allait devoir
diffuser dans des écrans d'une taille
restreinte des formats de vidéo de
différentes tailles différents aspects
cruciaux par si finalement tout est
différent que l'on tourne pas en quête
tiers comme à l'époque ont tous en 35 mm
70 mm c'est pas exactement la même
taille de rectangles et donc du coup il
fallait standardisés
un petit peu tout ce bordel sinon on est
à se retrouver avec des trucs qui sont
d'ailleurs je croyais littéralement
arrivée dans le monde réel pour un film
était diffusé à la télé avec les bords
de l'image coupé parce qu'il fallait
forcément zoomer dans les machines ont
salé être bizarre on avait juste avoir
un bout de film et le reste on pourrait
de barres noires qui et n'importe où ça
n'a pas de sens du coup littéralement
quand vous voyez des barres noires c'est
une façon de faire rentrer un format
dans l'écran dans lequel vous le
visionner rang comme ça de force tu vois
je rentre au québec
je fais des blagues ça c'est une
explication théorique fait en 2 minutes
30 par jean michel hardy mais je suis
sûr que françois
mais françois dr françois homme de
qualité françois hommes mais vraiment
mais qui sont bons le matin se réveille
il a pas mauvaise haleine le mec et
waimes à gulf unis comme moi qu'est
sylla françois sera encore mieux vous
renseigner à vous les studios
donc en gros les bandes noires ben c'est
tout simplement fait pour faire rentrer
des films qui sont au format 21 9ème qui
le format le plus répandu pour les films
de cinéma dans un écran 16 9ème qui est
forcément un petit peu plus haut
d'ailleurs il existe des écrans en
format 21 9ème et si vous regardez un
film qui est dans ce format là sur un
écran comme celui là vous aurez pas de
bandes noires logique mais comme dans la
majorité des cas nos écrans ils sont 16
9ème on a les bandes noires longue dans
le motel cinéma égale bande moi c'est
pourquoi nous passons maintenant à la
deuxième partie
comment on va créer ces fameuses bandes
noires moi je vois trois façons
différentes pour la créer il ya la
rapide mais limité la rapide mais fun et
la vraie de vraie alors la rapide mais
limité c'est hyper simple on va tout
simplement dans final cut aller chercher
les faits les torts box l'appliquer à
nos plans ou un ajustement de playoffs
c'est quand même plus simple pour la
globalité des plans on sélectionne le
format 2 35
et boum terminé on n'en parle plus allez
dégagez c'est fini pour en avoir
la deuxième façon celle que j'appelle la
rapide et fun et c'est celle dont on va
servir après pour la partie créative en
fin de vidéo
elle consiste tout simplement à utiliser
une image png avec un fond transparent
et ses fameuses bandes noires qu'on va
coller au dessus de nos plans alors on
va tout simplement placer notre image
png avec les bandes noires par dessus
les plans et ça se trouve hyper
facilement dans google images et même
moi je vous en mets une en
téléchargement
dans la description un petit drag and
drop on étire sur toute la vidéo et hop
c'est terminé là encore finger in the
nose
ouais je suis perdue en anglais question
enfin ce que j'appelle la vraie de vraie
c'est tout simplement faire du vrai 21/9
le format cinéma et le petit plus de
cette méthode là c'est que si vous
utilisez un écran ne serait-ce que les
smartphones qui est plus large que du
16/9 bas on n'aura pas des bandes noires
sur le côté parce que si on utilise le
png ou les faits les torts box etc en
garde la vidéo sur un écran au format 21
9ème ou plus large que le 16/9
mais on aura les bandes noires en haut
et en bas mais on a aussi des bandes
noires sur les côtés et ça c'est moche
c'est pas cool fera zoomer dans l'image
pour pouvoir mettre en plein écran donc
ça c'est pas top donc cette version là
avec le vrai format 21/9 la permettre
d'éviter ce petit écueil ici pour ça je
vais aller dans un nouveau projet et je
vais mettre des dimensions personnalisé
pour mon projet alors en hd ça me
donnera du 1920 par 800 et en cas de cas
ça me donnera du 1340 par 1600 ensuite
je vais pouvoir utiliser mes ruches en
16/9 que je vais devoir est tiré et
voilà on a notre film en format 21/9
format cinéma alors je vous ai montré
trois méthodes y en a pas forcément une
qui est meilleur que l'autre ça va
dépendre un petit peu du type de projet
que vous faites le lutteur boxe c'est un
petit peu la solution de facilité c'est
quelque chose qui va très vite
tout comme le psg leiter boxe ça
implique qu'on fera aucun petit effet
avec derrière on va le laisser comme ça
on va mettre des petits plans
cinématiques au milieu de vidéos de
plantes par exemple face caméra sur un
blog qui vont être en 16/9 puisque eux
n'ont pas d'utilité à être enfin terrain
9e c'est la solution de facilité on va
dire qu'ils n'aiment pas mauvaise mais
qui est un petit peu limité le psg quant
à lui on va plutôt l'utiliser quand on
va vouloir faire des petits effets comme
on va voir juste après et enfin la
solution qui consiste à faire du 21 9ème
là ça va être pour vraiment un film
complet qui va être dans son mât là
puisqu'on aura pas de possibilité
d'alterner le 16/9 et le vin terre
neuvienne on aura tous vraiment au même
format
donc vraiment pour du court métrage pour
un clip
cette méthode elle convient à des films
qui vont se vouloir un petit peu plus
cinéma maintenant passons à la dernière
partie on va essayer d'être un petit peu
créatif avec ses bandes noires et pas
juste les posez là et puis voir ce qui
se passe premiers effets qu'on peut
faire et qui est vachement sympa c'est
l'arrivée progressive de ces bandes
noires comme ici et pour cet effet on va
utiliser le
ça me png alors c'est hyper facile j'ai
placé mon png je me mets au début et au
niveau de l'échelle je vais placer une
qui fring et puis je vais l'agrandir
pour qu'elle ne soit plus visible dans
le cadre ensuite j'avance de quelques
secondes
et là je vais remettre l'échelle à 100%
et bim entrée progressive des banques
doit totalement easy et effet garanti un
autre effet sympa qu'on va pouvoir très
facilement impliqué ça va être un genre
de riz ville chaude qui va révéler la
scène au fur et à mesure que les bernois
ces cartes pour commencer je vais
laisser mon png tel qu'il est et je
toucherai pas parce que ça m'évitera de
me prendre la tête avec les dimensions
ensuite je vais ajouter un fond noir uni
que je vais placer à la moitié de
l'image comme ça ensuite je pose une qui
friment je décale de quelques secondes
et je fais sortir l'image par le bas
maintenant je vais répéter l'opération
poser un deuxième fonds noirs mais cette
fois ci pour la moitié du haut lac
iframe
je me déplace je fais sortir cette fois
ci ce fond noir par le haut et bout on a
une petite entrée en matière bien sympa
et voilà là je crois qu'on a fait le
tour de ce qu'on pouvait dire sur les
bandes noires on a plus parlé d'un
hameau refik mais ce n'était pas
vraiment à propos
donc ça à la limite on en parlera
peut-être dans une autre vidéo mais il
ya aussi ar disque que je remercie
grandement d'avoir participé à cette
vidéo qui en a fait une qui est super
bien sur la nam orphique donc allé voir
si vous n'êtes pas abonné à la chine
d'art disent qu'il faut y aller c'est un
mec super super super cool
moi je les aime beaucoup et puisqu'on
arrive à la fin de cette vidéo il ya
quelques jours on a passé le cap des
vingt mille abonnés c'est juste barjots
j'avais mis trois ans pour en avoir dix
mille et là il a fallu un peu plus de
six mois pour passer à 20 milles et et
c'est juste énorme c'est ça me fait
hyper plaisir de voir que vous êtes de
plus en plus nombreux à suivre ces
vidéos à interagir dans les commentaires
et et à apprendre grâce à ce que je vous
propose donc ça ça me fait super plaisir
c'est vraiment le but de cette chaîne
vous proposer du contenu pour vous aidez
moi j'apprends des trucs aussitôt je
vous fais une vidéo sans prétention sans
vous dire qu'il faut faire comme ça
j'ai trouvé un truc sympa je vous le
montre et écoutez vous me le rende et
bien et ça fait vraiment hyper plaisir
c'est juste énorme je suis sur le cul je
suis hyper content et c'est grâce à vous
donc j'en profite à la fin de cette
vidéo ici là pour vous dire un immense
merci
et puis j'en profite bien évidemment
pour vous souhaiter une très très très
très bonne année 2010 9 un peu en retard
je n'ai pas sorti une vidéo de bonne
année comme tout le monde moi je suis
toujours à la bourre toujours à la
bourre une très très bonne année 2010 9
à vous que vous ayez plein de vidéos
plein de photos plein de bonheur pour
2010 et puis comme d'habitude les amis
n'hésitez pas à mettre le traditionnel
coup deux blaster sur le pouce en l'air
si cette vidéo vous a plu abonnez-vous
si ce n'est pas déjà fait venir
rejoindre les 20 mille abonnés qui sont
déjà sur cette chaîne laissez moi un
commentaire si vous avez des choses à
dire sur cette vidéo si vous voulez nous
partager des astuces puis moi je vous
dis comme d'habitude rester curieux et à
très bientôt pour une prochaine vidéo
d'ailleurs comme iliaque les vrais de
vrai qu'il reste jusqu'à la fin de la
vidéo je vous pose la question à vous
est ce qu'une faq comme font tous les
youtuber ça vous plairait si c'est le
cas mettez des questions pour la faq
dans les commentaires et puis si on a
suffisamment on fera une vidéo spéciale
faq spéciale 20 mille abonnés pour
répondre à toutes les questions que vous
vous posez
non